2022 was the year when Cole was king at
one point it was providing more than a
third of all Germany's energy with the
war in Ukraine taking Russian
hydrocarbons off the market coal from
elsewhere became the easiest go-to
energy source power stations were
reactivated to burn it
liquefied natural gas or LNG was another
watchword new terminals were built on
the North Sea Coast to accommodate super
tankers carrying it and a long-term deal
to acquire 2 million tons of Qatari LNG
each year was signed but in the short
term analysts say ministers will have to
adapt their green agenda they will do
more of what they have done already
Foster additional energy supplies make
sure they can come in also through
German LNG Terminals and a huge step
forward will be to reduce demand further
a lot needs to be done in households
still because buildings need to be need
to be insulated heating systems need to
be changed you can't do all of this in
2023 but it needs to start now the other
metaphorical elephant in the room is
nuclear three reactors which were due to
go offstream permanently have been
temporarily kept in operation this
provides around six percent of the
energy Germany uses annually but that's
far as the green party in government is
prepared to go anti-nuclear sentiment is
so entrenched in Germany in in large
parts of the population that it's it's
going to be relatively hard to to Really
especially for the greens if they want
to keep their credibility to to go on to
to prolong uh nuclear power indefinitely
maybe for a few more months maybe for a
year but I don't think in the long run
in Germany uh nuclear power will have
any future but that sort of view is not
shared by many in the German Parliament
who believe nuclear energy has a clear
role to play and for some time yet
just by extending the life of the
remaining three nuclear power plants we
ultimately achieved far too little
instead we need continued operation
until at least the end of 2024 that is
what we are proposing now and we need
new fuel for them
to contemplate such a move is painful
for many in the current governments most
of them have spent their entire adult
lives campaigning against fossil fuels
and nuclear power and yet this is where
Decades of deepening dependence on
Russian energy has brought them
environmentalism may provide fire in
their bellies but it seems unlikely to
provide much heat and light in millions
of homes this winter Dominic Kane Al
Jazeera Berlin